this is an incredible opportunity
for others but i'm wondering
what you get out of this opportunity
what you get out of doing something like
this
with telling your story i want to give
the opportunity to canadians to hear
about what it's like
to move to los angeles how you do it why
it's good for you or not good for you
you know when i first moved to la i
literally rented out a closet and a
bedroom
and i shared it with two other canadians
that were coming down to la
i had a ton of questions so i just want
to walk people
through that process and i want to tell
people a little bit about
you know the obstacles i i went through
to even just
go to theater school you know i came
from an ethnically diverse background
and my parents didn't want me you know
my parents wanted me to be a doctor so
i just want to share that with with
people back home
and mena is using his platform to help
other ethnically diverse
artists as well the master class will be
raising money for his eda foundation
which supports
diversity in hollywood if you're a young
white actor you have a lot to worry
about but but that's not one of the
things
when did you realize that this was
something else on a journey of becoming
a successful
actor that you are going to have to sort
of push through and overcome that many
others wouldn't have to
i think a lot of brown people don't talk
about it but life changed after 9 11 for
all of us
and in the acting world i mean listen my
first professional
actra union role was al qaeda number two
on nikita so
i knew right off the bat this was you
know this is how it's gonna be
you gotta fight your way out of that and
i think we're doing that slowly
but you know it it is a battle when it
comes to the the backup plan because a
lot of convincing of the parents
is is you know okay you let me go and do
this
but i'll still have the backup plan do
you still have the backup plan that you
and your parents talk about
like this that still exist that doesn't
exist but
up until aladdin it did as a brown kid
as an ethnic kid
going to theater school is like deciding
the rest of your life
because your parents put such an
emphasis on it so even before i went to
theater school and making that decision
dropping out of neuroscience at uft i
said
i'm gonna do this or i'm gonna die
trying and i i've stuck to that man i'm
gonna do this or die trying
that's it now i'm in a whole new
world i know we talked about this the
last time but uh what's the latest
according to you
on aladdin 2 anything new since the last
time we talked
no nothing new i know that they have
lots of meetings internally they're
trying to figure out
uh the story of it you know dan lynn our
producers come out and talked about that
they're not going to go return of jafar
you know animated version they're not
doing that they want to come up with an
original idea
i imagine they're they're focusing on
that stuff